you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and I'm going to do
another group of three puzzles and
simply share my thoughts along the way
so let's dive right in and see what we
go climbing is white and this first one
okay well what can we do here my first
thought was Bishop f6 and if King takes
Knight we would have Queen b8 Queen d8
and then Queen takes Queen me however
after Bishop f6 and King g8 there is now
not a good follow up black does not have
to take the night out and reply to
Bishop f6 so what about something else
yeah and Bishop f6 King g8 if we don't
have a good follow-up check we're in
trouble
step stuff like Bishop f6 King g8 and
then Queen h6 we're in some serious
trouble with rook a4 Queen b3 and our
King gets walked down we're in trouble
so we don't have time for this quiet
move so I'm trying to find a way to give
back to back checks
how could we do that for a moment I
thought about night here first 96 on
pawn takes Knight Queen f8 is checkmate
Knight here
Queen takes however what are we doing
there I don't see it
okay what other first moves were there P
there's a knight check a bishop check we
don't have any good Queen checks here
Queen h6 a Queen sacrifice isn't working
hmmm for a moment I thought is there
some way to mmm stalemate our own king
like can we win this position even we
don't know that much I'm thinking we
could still but how would we do that
hmmm a bit stuck here Bishop f6 King g8
am i certain that that leads to nothing
pretty certain yeah there's also this
check if we're not quick enough okay
with 96 Queen takes Knight Queen d4 [ __ ]
maybe if the King moves and replied to
this 96 Queen takes Knight Queen d4 we
are on the rook
so if King h6 let's just say Bishop g5 s
me if the King goes to the back our
queen from d4 would play to d8 and then
play to f8 for me so this has my
attention
96 Queen takes Knight Queen d4 I'm
thinking the best reply in that position
has to be f6 as otherwise I think black
is getting mated and from there I guess
we could take the rook but that leaves
us open to several checks does it not
96 Queen takes Knight Queen d4 f6 Queen
takes rook we're preparing to move our
bishop with a discover check oh my
goodness oh my goodness this is such a
cool puzzle I see the solution now oh
man haha I really like this one man this
is cool
96 is correct the Queen takes Knight we
don't play Queen d4 we play Queen h6
King takes Queen Bishop f8 is mate
we give up our knight in Queen in order
to finish off with Bishop f8 this is
cool I like this one so this is a mate
puzzle 96 context is Queen FA 96 Queen
takes Knight there's Queen h6 if King
two one of these two Queen f8 is mate
King takes Queen Bishop f8 mate
the bishop alone is enough oh that's
clever I really like this one Queen h6
that's cool what a start
I like that puzzle maybe I only liked it
cuz I got the solution but that's a
pretty clever sequence of boosts I like
that tempting to go Bishop f6 but it's
important to realize that our checks
simply run out we don't have a good
follow up after King g8 Bishop f6 King
g8 there's not a good check and we're in
trouble okay let's try a puzzle - neat
sequence
alright we're playing is white in this
one and I'm drawn immediately to Queen
of six and we can give check force the
King to f8 and when that happens the
pawn is pinned to the king so what's
quite common is to attack the pinned
piece Queen f6 King f8 g6 threatens g7
mate
I think that that's working mm-hmm and
let's see how black really stops that
notice unlike puzzle one from yeah
unlike puzzle one this one here we can
afford a quiet move like g6 a move that
is not giving check or you know making a
capture but it's certainly throwing a
strong punch we're threatening and
making one but we can afford to not give
a check with one of our moves Queen f6
King F a g6 how do you stop g7 and
Bishop h6 but the bishop is on an
unprotected square and so I believe from
that position queen of six King f8 g6
Bishop h6 I think that we can play on
takes pawn we're attacking the rook and
we are attacking the bishop hmm what
would block to their Queen check King f8
g6 Bishop h6 I'll take spun how we do
materialize also we're down to minor
pieces so you should be careful here
just the win of the bishop is not going
to be enough most likely but I mean we
could be capturing the bishop with
checks so let's see Queen f6 King f8 g6
Bishop h6 defending g7 mate
I believe in that position we can play
on takes pawn threatening the rub
threatening the bishop suppose Queen
takes pawn in that position after Queen
takes pawn Queen takes bishop check
couple options from there if the Queen
blocks we would have rook f1 and that
distracts the Queen excuse me that would
distract the King away from defense of
the Queen Queen of six King Fe g6 Bishop
h6 pawn takes Queen takes Queen takes
Bishop check suppose in that position
the King moves to e7 where would our
Queen go I believe in that position the
Queen would go to g5 hmm this is tricky
now because after Queen of six I'm not
sure what the follow-up would be there a
lot of pieces have moved I'm trying to
envision that position where these two
pawns are no longer around nor is this
Bishop and we have a queen on g5 our
queen on g5 and their queen is on f6 and
their King is exactly right here any 7
so what would we do there we could from
g5 make use of c5 I see that but what I
do not see is what we would do after
King f7 in that position I do not see
what the good follow up would be there
something unmov'd to is g6 really the
idea is there some other little trick
that I'm missing Queen f6 King f8 Queen
h8 the king has to go back our queen is
hit I don't see anything from that
position other than the Queen coming
back to f6 we could have a perpetual hmm
I'm thinking there is more here but we
have the perpetual if we really wanted
it Queen f6 to h8 so let me look at
something more Queen o 6 King f8 still
g6 Bishop h6 should I change up my move
3 what would move 3 even V hmm oh I
wonder is there time for like getting
our rook to H 1 H 1 to H 8 um no I
really don't see that it'd be different
if we didn't have our Bishop here Queen
f6 King f8 the rook can come over right
away looking for rookie jate mate but
our Bishop is in the way and also black
can be quick to challenge our queen its
Queen e5 stuff so that seems a bit slow
trying to work with the Queen and rook
converging on the h8 square in summary
hmm I'm pretty locked in to Queen f6 on
move one so I don't see any other start
and I don't want to move there right
away I want to try and get this one from
the initial position I think that's the
correct approach instead of going one
move at a time
move to I think has to be g6 Queen f6
King f8 g6 Bishop h6 is there any trick
with g7 Bishop takes and then you know
by forcing that takes away square from
the King I don't see anything happening
in this direction though let's see how
we get up the king along this diagonal
Queen check King f8 g6 Bishop h6 pawn
takes Queen takes pawn is there
something different there I think it
would be Queen takes bishop then King
here man what would we do there hmm I
guess we could from that position with
the King on e7 and the Queen on f7 I
guess we could play Bishop g6 attacking
the Queen attacking the rook and
preparing bishop or excuse me preparing
Queen h7 so I mean it turns out maybe
and that there's a quiet move several
moves in with this variation because I
don't really see what this Queen g5 is
doing after black would play Queen f6
Queen c5 king f7 it's not like we can
take advantage I don't think at least of
the Queen and King being on the same
file with our queen on c5 we don't have
this rook f1 stuff maybe that is what it
is
maybe that's what it is Queen f6 King F
a g6 Bishop h6 pawn takes pawn Queen
takes pawn
Queen takes Bishop King e7 Bishop g6 I
think that's what it might be the King
goes to f8 then we have this idea where
we could give a check on the h7 square
the King can't go any here and if he
comes over to the F file enter now the
rook that must be what it is I don't
know what more to even look at let's
just run with it you know that's correct
is g6 even correct yes pawn takes pawn
incorrect
okay where did I make my mistake here
well I know where I made my mistake but
what move was I missing this is not
correct to take the pawn here why not
all right let's see what the solution is
clean check g6 it's just pulling it out
now rook f1 I wasn't even close didn't
consider that quiet move rook f1 mmm
let's go back broke f1 that's tricky
rook F 1 at this point how tempting it
is to just take here no hmm okay that's
a tough one rook f1 there wouldn't be
Bishop he just go into the analysis for
a moment this was the puzzle start push
here takes mmm oh this this is the move
work f1 and this move would not be
working because we could actually may I
see that much now hmm we still are
threatening this mate what did the
computer do I believe it went with the
rook and then there was this that's
pretty sharp check and then the Queen
coming over here and eventually picking
off the black Queen I wonder a little
bit about my choice still just really so
bad
mmm-hmm maybe they could just do without
the rook there's something like this
working but this was my idea this was
what I was calculating I saw if Queen
here there's this and that's a good way
to pick up the Queen next and also if
King here bishop g6 I thought would have
been good because it seems like we're
getting here next no this may still be
winning mm-hmm I don't know it's kind of
tricky does black even have to take
here's another important question maybe
supposed black can just pitch the rook
allow this double check and then where
are we going from here oh we could give
a check at the Queen blocks we could
give a check here with our rook I don't
know I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to work this for now maybe you guys can
help me out with this one in the comment
section below
is there still an okay continuation
maybe you could help out with this one
clearly didn't get the the very best but
I wonder if this is still a good idea to
take the pawn I don't know give me some
feedback on that be sure to give some
insight I'm sure there will be others
that are wanting to have some closer to
this one I sure want some closure but
yeah give some feedback in the comments
to this one and let's see how we could
do with this final puzzle got number two
wrong let's see if we could finish two
out of three okay I think I could manage
this one oh this is pretty cool I think
I know the solution yeah I like this one
mmm this is pretty cool I like this okay
like to move pretty sure I know this one
my first thought was to play king d3
that was like the first my first the
first second I thought king d3 and then
I thought wait a second we could play
Bishop a1 and there's the potential to
force this beep on to move on Bishop a1
King takes bishop we can play King c1 is
my first thought b6 or b5 probably be 5
C 6 b 4 c 7 b 3 if we get a queen they
play b2 it's check
I mean I have to do some calculating but
there might be something connected with
this bishop a one idea it might be much
simpler than I'm making it out to be
can we actually just play king d3 allow
this pawn to push we take the pawn king
takes King c4 King b2 king b5 King b3
king b6 king c4 we take the pawn they
take our pawn it's just not working
so going like this is not gonna work out
with King d3 so I think it must be
Bishop to a one move one and I think I
guess I think I need to make an
adjustment on move to Bishop a one king
takes bishop would it really be king c1
or maybe there's a point with King c2 I
think that that's what it is yeah
there's a big difference between these
two Bishop a1 King takes bishop let me
revisit this once more king c1 the King
and pawn can now not move black has to
try pushing the pawn and he might as
well try to go two squares if we take
the pawn it's damning so the idea here
is to me to move like b5 with c6 so
let's see their King is on a one let's
try King c1 I'm thinking it's king c2
just by that initial calculation but let
me revisit king c1 first after the king
is on c1 black plays b5 we must play c6
if we're trying to win so running this
little test
b5 c6 b for c7 v 3 we get a queen
black gets to push next with check if we
go to see - they're promoting again with
Chuck that's not working out that'd be
two widths check is not going to cut it
so the correct second move must be king
- see - Bishop a1 King a1 King see -
how's this different B 5 C 6 v 4 c7 b3
King takes pawn or in Czech at that
point King now has a move king b1 now we
promote black and promote to a queen but
in the end our King is on b3 they have a
queen on a1 their king is on be one
Queen c2 would be mating in the end -
Queens on the board but we have our
queen on c2 delivering mate black can
give a check and that's maybe what the
computer would do at that point when our
King is on b3 and we have just promoted
maybe they'll promote to a knight wits
check but that's no big issue we'll just
move the King out of the way and it'll
be made soon thereafter that must be
what it is Bishop a1 that is correct
in King c2 very important he goes there
and we pushed through we take the pawn
let me get a queen and I'm guessing
again they're gonna get a knight
no they just allow Queen c2 for me
okay two out of three
I definitely need some help on puzzle
number two so any insight you can offer
on that one would be appreciated the
first puzzle was awesome let me know if
you got you guys got that one that was
pretty cool sacking the night sacking
the Queen and then with just a bishop on
board versus a queen and rook that was a
very cool mate I like that one okay
well as usual feel free to let me know
how you did with these three in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now
take care
you